so I want to start with and I've been
bringing this up in all the interviews I
wasn't sure Dwayne has talked to me for
years and years about Black Adam and
what he wanted to do but with all of his
recent movies he's like a little more
family friendly I wasn't sure he was
really going to kill people I wasn't
sure he was really gonna go for it and
he totally goes for it he kills everyone
oh yeah and it's going to sort of talk
about that like Dwayne does not pull any
punches in this as far as Black Adam no
I think we have one of the highest body
counts do we really yeah it was all
super the genre really I think so I mean
outside of
that was a pretty high body count
obviously that's a universe that doesn't
make sense it doesn't existing my
fingers
and you see it's been building up for
for uh DJ he's like I'm gonna let it out
one day and when I do and he's
dangerous for both of you I am so
curious look I love learning about like
the behind the scenes and the making of
a film this is one of these massive
movies with tons of moving Parts what do
you think soon to be fans of Black Adam
would be surprised to learn about like
the actual making of the movie wow
surprised to know about the making of
the movie dude we all hung out on set
offset and we still continue to hang out
to this day the chemistry that you that
you can feel on screen is comes from a
very real place it's not fabricated it's
not even really acted
um
and it fueled the entire for me it
fueled the entire movie making process
yeah that was
that highlight of a project for all of
us thousand percent
we can we all agree we all feel that way
we all talk about it so we can you know
hypothetically do another we would like
to right if you want us to I mean let us
know I am going to I'll I'll say it
right here on the interview I'm going to
be shocked if this movie does not get a
sequel literally shocked just you can
take it to the bank I've seen it at
least five movies so I know what I'm
talking about hey it's like guys
you got me beat right looking at what
you had to do in the movie and all the
stuff that goes on on set was there a
day in the shoot that you had circled in
your calendar in terms of oh this is
going to be a pain in the ass day
for me I never knew when the day was
going to come
but because the schedule shifted pretty
commonly but like it happened to be the
last day of like when we were rapping
and that was my Cyclone day where I did
all of like my my stunts whoa it was
everything in one day and so I was just
like okay okay okay what's the
choreography like how are we gonna do it
do we have the right type of flooring to
do this that and a third but that was
incredible that was the day I loved the
most and like felt this project the most
on that day wow in a very beautiful way
what about you
mocap never done it before performance
cap it was my first time ever doing it
and uh I knew it was gonna come and uh
but I was I was not regretting it I was
just like that's the day where I get to
explore a completely new medium
never done it before
so fun I'm curious with motion capture
was it something that at the end of the
day you're like oh this isn't that bad
or were you like oh I don't need to do
this anytime again soon I would love to
do more
I would love to do more of it yeah for
this character for sure and and for
I can imagine if I played a lizard
or a cat
or cue
I'm gonna switch real quick because
otherwise I'm going to watch you two
laugh for the next time no it's totally
fine
uh so obviously every movie has deleted
scenes yeah was there a scene for each
of you that you were sad
that you were sad to see go I was I was
so upset
there's some like you know at the end of
the day like you know this film does
what it's supposed to do and is the way
it is because it's just it's perfect
um but there was a little bit in the
beginning with my character that I was
just like no it would have like
developed it a little bit more but I
think where everything is at now just
truly will set up a foundation and have
people be interested to dive into all of
the characters and like really see how
we build things out so it's good you
know can't give too much
looking for you
I really like that scene that you're
talking about yeah because it was
[Music]
but I really like your cues or Cyclones
part of that
I thought that part was sick but but I
agree this film is what it is uh well
hopefully the Blu-ray yeah can't wait to
see it on Blu-ray yeah I'm talking about
the deleted scene but anyways
no I'm just specifically talking about
that but on that note I thought you say
the whole thing I was like that's crazy
you said blue wraps oh
they're still making blueberry
congratulations for real it's gonna be a
huge hit thank you for your time thank
you